لقد أخبرتم المراسلين أه في
الأيام الأخيرة أن على الناتو أن يقتبس يرسل
إشارة واضحة لروسيا
بشأن نشاطها العسكري
كما قلتم أنه ستكون هناك
عواقب سياسية واقتصادية خطيرة إذا
غزت روسيا
ما هي تلك العواقب ماذا
سيفعل الناتو إذا عبرت روسيا؟  الحدود
لذا ندعو روسيا أولاً وقبل كل شيء
إلى عدم استخدام القوة العسكرية
ضد
أوكرانيا مرة أخرى ،
ندعوهم إلى التحلي بالشفافية
لخفض التصعيد وتقليل التوترات إذا
قرروا على الرغم من ذلك
استخدام القوة العسكرية مرة أخرى لغزو أوكرانيا ،
فسيكون هناك  يكون ثمناً باهظاً ندفعه
لروسيا ،
لدينا مجموعة واسعة من الخيارات
العقوبات الاقتصادية العقوبات المالية
والقيود السياسية وأيضًا بعد
المرة الأخيرة التي
نفذ فيها الناتو بالفعل أكبر
تعزيز لدفاعنا الجماعي
منذ نهاية الحرب الباردة مع
مجموعات قتالية جاهزة للقتال  في
الجزء الشرقي من الجزر
في دول البلطيق بهذه الطريقة حيث نحن
الآن ولكن أيضًا في البحر الأسود
gion وجميع هذه الخيارات مطروحة على
الطاولة ، هل تقول أن الرد العسكري
على غزو روسي مطروح على الطاولة ،
وأعتقد أنه من المهم التمييز
بين
أوكرانيا ، وأوكرانيا شريك نقدم
الدعم والتدريب لبناء القدرات ،
كما يوفر الحلفاء بعض المعدات
العسكرية
الأجهزة وهذه دولة
شريكة لأوكرانيا ،
فلدينا حلفاء الناتو
مثل رومانيا ، بلغاريا ،
بولندا ، دول البلطيق في
الجزء الشرقي من التحالف بالنسبة لهم ، نحن
نقدم ضمانات أمنية ، نقول إنه
إذا تعرضت إحدى تلك الدول للهجوم
، فسوف يستجيب التحالف بأكمله.
سوف نأتي وندافع عنهم ، لذا فإن هذا
فرق بين كوننا
شريكًا ذا قيمة عالية في
أوكرانيا ، فنحن ندعمهم وحلفاء الناتو
حيث نقدم ضمانات أمنية مطلقة